an active duty US soldier who was
deployed twice to fight terrorists is
now in custody on terrorism charges an
FBI SWAT team detained akaike Kang in
Hawaii on Saturday after he pledged
allegiance to Isis he allegedly told an
undercover agent that he wanted to kill
a bunch of people Jephthah gazes at FBI
headquarters with more on this story
Jeff good morning good morning according
to investigators the 34 year old US
soldier had been inspired by Isis over
at least a five-year period Army
sergeant first class akaike Kang
appeared in federal court on Monday in
Honolulu accused of attempting to
provide material support or resources to
Isis court papers describe how Kang
handed over 18 secret level military
documents to undercover agents that he
believed could help Isis on Saturday
before his arrest he pledged allegiance
to the Islamic state and made combat
training videos that he believed would
be shown to Isis fighters Kang enlisted
in the Army just months after the 9/11
attacks and he served one tour in Iraq
in 2012 Kang had his military clearance
revoked for making pro Islamic state
comments but he was eventually
reinstated and in 2013 was deployed to
Afghanistan now this case stands out but
in recent weeks the Department of
Justice has announced a series of
terrorism related cases and arrests the
FBI has said that it is investigating
hundreds of terrorism cases across the
country Charlie Jeff thanks